joystick junkies playing too many video
games is an illness it's what parents of
fortnite fanatics have been saying all
along
these are just a handful of the
headlines from 2018 that followed the
news that the world health organization
had defined gaming disorder in its
international classification of diseases
from fortnight to candy crush concerns
have long been raised about game's
addictive potential but for it to be
classified as a distinct disorder was a
big step however the psychology
community found itself divided some
psychologists believe the who's decision
was based on poorly constructed research
and could even spark a moral panic we're
not
that far advanced in our understanding
of something that you might want to call
video game addiction now compared to 20
years ago really meanwhile here in the
uk psychologists at a specialist run
clinic have reported success at treating
the condition we've been quite surprised
how severe it can be for those that are
actually affected so was the who right
to make this decision and does gaming
addiction really exist
in 2018 gaming disorder was outlined in
the icd-11 the latest version of a
manual which outlines health conditions
around the world the diagnostic criteria
for gaming disorder essentially boils
down to these factors persisting over a
period of at least 12 months also
included are boundaries of normality
these ensure that normal behaviors like
using games to alleviate boredom or
playing games to socialize with friends
are no indication anything is wrong
those boundaries of normality are
important because they outline the
difference between a normal healthy
relationship to gaming and an unhealthy
harmful one which helps limit the
potential for misdiagnosis by worried
parents who might not know all that much
about gaming it's also useful for the
mainstream press as it helps ensure the
condition is reported with the level of
nuance and detail that such a serious
subject matter calls for
yeah about that the who's announcement
led to a predictable response with the
sort of panic inducing headlines we saw
earlier phrases like kids addicted to
video games like fortnite will now have
the condition recognized as an official
mental disorder seen tailor-made to make
parents rip the controllers from their
kids hands and throw their playstations
out the window by the way it's
interesting that they keep mentioning
fortnite but we'll come back to that
this is pete echels he's a professor of
psychology and science communication at
bath spa university and the author of
lost in a good game a book about the
psychological effects good and bad of
video games if you look at worries about
obsessive play with video games they've
been around since the early 1980s bunch
of doctors who had these three guys that
came into their clinic that all
presented with very similar symptoms all
three of them were on the verge of
getting married all three of them
developed quite
strong obsessions with playing space
invaders so they take this sort of weird
psychoanalytic freudian approach to it
and say well the reason that they became
obsessed with space invaders is because
they saw themselves as the tank
and their prospective brides to be with
a invading alien force coming into their
homes which is a really depressing way
of thinking about marriage it was the
start in a way of this
worry around you know you look at
somebody playing video game and they're
really engrossed in it they play it for
a long time this maybe doesn't seem
right we're not
that far advanced in our understanding
of something that you might want to call
video game addiction now compared to 20
years ago really in the wake of the
who's decision pete was one of a number
of psychologists around the world who
voiced his concerns co-authoring a
comment paper that called for the who to
er on the side of caution this paper was
one of dozens published by psychologists
many of whom took issue with the ways
much of the research into gaming
disorder had been conducted by adapting
questionnaires designed to measure other
addictions we know that there are other
things that are addictive so let's take
established scales and questionnaires
and measures for those things take that
questionnaire that's got say 10 15 20
statements that you say very untrue or
very true of you about gambling and you
just replace the word gambling with
gaming so you've got this new gaming
addiction questionnaire now and you give
that to a thousand people and you will
get a spread of scores right some people
who score zero some people score 100 and
you decide if you score 60 or more
you're considered addicted to games are
you measuring gaming addiction though
because the way that those statements
were originally constructed makes sense
for gambling maybe doesn't make so much
sense for gaming we've never really got
past that problem one major issue with
all of this is that there's very little
concrete evidence showing how much of
the population might be affected in its
reasoning the who points to a number of
reviews it commissioned studying the
prevalence of gaming disorder across the
world but the results across these
studies suggest the condition might
affect anywhere from
0.21 to 57.5
of the gaming population the results are
so varied that even the authors of the
who commissioned report urged a cautious
approach but this is a really important
thing to get right in 2019 a survey of
over 2 000 parents found that half of
them feared their children were becoming
addicted to playing games but with no
concrete evidence to show exactly how
many gamers are affected it's hard to
know how well-founded those fears might
be the range of 0.1.2
up to
more than 50
is a huge range right so something's
wrong there and we're kind of rushing to
do research in this area because
everybody's worried about fortnight
being addictive or whatever because
that's what we see in the news and
parents care about this sort of stuff
and it's understandable why but we're
not taking the time to just slow down
and
think about how we study this
objectively and
however outside of research psychology
the who's decision had another
potentially more significant impact on
those people who have actually been
diagnosed with the condition as a direct
result of the addition of gaming
disorder to the icd-11 specialist
centers began to open offering treatment
for the condition in london we visited
the national center for gaming disorders
the only state-funded uk clinic
dedicated to treating the condition and
spoke to rebecca lockwood a consultant
clinical psychologist about the impact
of the condition on those who suffer
from it for the people that we see in
the clinic we've been struck by actually
quite quite how much of an impact this
has on the game of themselves and the
families often there's kind of violence
and aggression often they are involved
in other services mental health services
social services are involved we've been
kind of struck by the amount of kind of
risk for those that
struggle with this addiction also the
impact on physical health malnourishment
often people are quite underweight
because they're not feeding themselves
on average we we would see people gaming
maybe 10-12 hours a day and that would
be often during night that will lead to
difficulties with attending school and
work so we're not we're not talking
about a few hours we're talking about
considerable period of that person's
life that
is spent gaming since opening in 2019 a
year after the who's decision the clinic
reports it has been overwhelmed with
referrals for treatment 70 of which are
for people aged 18 or under in many
cases gaming begins as an immersive and
rewarding way to escape from reality
something that i'd imagine resonates
with many of us who play games but that
escape becomes an unhealthy compulsion
we have seen within those that have
self-selected to come to the clinic
quite high levels of autistic spectrum
disorder and adhd and also high levels
of social anxiety we've seen people that
have come to the clinic because there's
been an event in their life such as
bullying or parents divorce or kind of
transition from junior to senior school
and often that's been the kind of
trigger for them to start to use gaming
as an escape and then the gaming in
itself has become kind of a secondary
problem there's some kind of patterns
even though we can't kind of quantify
them at the moment but we have seen some
patterns of people that typically refer
to the clinic many of the arguments
against including gaming disorder in the
icd-11 center around the lack of
evidence that gaming itself is causing
harm but does that actually matter if
the result is a clinic that helps people
deal with both the symptom and the
underlying cause following treatment
many patients at the national center for
gaming disorders report an improvement
in their quality of life and a healthier
relationship to gaming it's important to
know that unlike some press outlets the
clinic does not demonize gaming at all
through their treatment nor do they
support banning gaming entirely
something that came as a surprise
instead they're well aware of the
positive impact gaming can have we're
looking at not abstaining which might be
how you treat some other
addictions but actually changing the
balance and the relationship because
often it will be that gaming has
completely taken over that person's life
so we start to look at how to
reintroduce other activities to start to
motivate people to go back to school or
work addressing some of the underlying
factors and enabling them to function in
a way where they don't need to use
gaming as a
kind of coping strategy
it's not a surprise that clinical
psychologists like rebecca are in favor
of the who's decision when they work
directly with patients clearly for some
people gaming can have a really negative
influence on their relationships and
their mental health the decision to
define gaming disorder has in that sense
done some good as it's enabled people to
access the care and support that they
need for some though the concern is that
with little evidence to pinpoint how
much of the population are actually
affected some people may slip through
the cracks my worry with it all is that
we're not capturing the people we need
to capture there are treatments that
will do something right but you don't
want to be treating a symptom you want
to be treating the cause so you don't
want people to relapse or relapse into
another form of addiction i don't think
the research base is good enough i think
we need to do a lot of work before we
get to that point one thing that clearly
doesn't help is the sort of
sensationless reporting we talked about
earlier dramatic headlines risk
demonizing gaming among non-gamers as
something that's incredibly toxic and
harmful but it also risks creating a
sense among gamers that this is simply a
moral panic and that psychologists are
just trying to take their games away
from them also fortnight as it turns out
is not quite the problem some would have
you believe gaming generally is healthy
so like we talked about about the
balance and the impact and the
associated distress so for most people
this will not be
a problem i think the media can help
increase understanding and awareness but
i think it has a responsibility to be
kind of proportional in its discussions
and actually the majority of our young
people probably don't pay for like
there's a range of different games but
often that's not one of the
ones that they play rebecca wouldn't be
drawn on which games they do see a lot
but some clinical psychologists have
called for governmental bodies to
regulate the games industry and hold
them accountable for the impact of games
with gameplay loops that could encourage
compulsive play unsurprisingly so far
games developers have been unwilling to
share data with addiction specialists
that could shed some light on how people
engage with their games given the lack
of progress regulating something like
loot boxes any meaningful regulation on
gaming addiction seems unlikely
speaking of which next week's episode of
mind games is all about loot boxes so
make sure you're subscribed and check
your feeds for that next week in the
short term at least i find it kind of
comfort to know that people are
researching games and the effect that
they can have on us in our mental health
and also that clinics are available for
people who may feel like they have a
problem if you're watching this video
and you feel like you might need to
speak to somebody about addiction there
are links below the video to services in
both the uk and the us that can help
i'll see you next time